[Música]
Hola son muchos los acontecimientos que
tienen lugar en una semana en el mundo
por eso aquí en France 24 hemos creado
este espacio semanal para conversar
debatir y analizar con periodistas
editorialistas y analistas sobre los
temas que concentraron nuestra atención
en los medios de comunicación para este
primer programa para nuestro Debut hemos
invitado a munie jensen ella es
periodista Partner de dentons global
advicer los saludo muni Gracias por
acompañarnos qué tal termina su semana
Gracias muy bien y muy contenta de estar
aquí en el debut de este programa
Felicidades también está con nosotros
Alba Lucía Reyes ellas periodista ella
se encuentra en la ciudad de Madrid en
España Alba Lucía bienvenida también al
programa y qué tal terminó usted la
semana Cómo llega el viernes
muy bien Santiago Muchísimas gracias
buenas tardes aquí desde Madrid y
también muy contenta de estar en este
nuevo programa una semana en el mundo
con ustedes Gracias para acompañarnos y
aquí en el estudio de France 24 nos
acompaña Carlos Sanabria él es editor
Internacional de la Radio Nacional de
Colombia Carlos Gracias por acompañarnos
bienvenido Cómo terminó esta semana Uy
con bastantes noticias Santiago Gracias
por esta invitación y por esta
oportunidad de estrenar con France 24
este espacio y también está con nosotros
Fátima Martínez fotógrafa documentalista
y periodista también se encuentra acá
con nosotros en el estudio Fátima
bienvenida qué tal termina su semana
Pues muy bien y encantada de estar aquí
gracias por acompañarnos a los cuatro
invitados de este programa Debut el les
recuerdo que ustedes también pueden
dejar todos sus comentarios preguntas y
opiniones a través de las redes sociales
arroba
france24_es@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal y nuestra etiqueta para que
dejen sus comentarios es numeral una
semana en el mundo f24 Pues esta semana
vimos como en el este y en el sur de
Ucrania cuatro regiones ocupadas por
Rusia realizaron referendos en los que
aprobaron su incorporación a la
federación de Rusia el presidente de la
federación Vladimir Putin firmó ya ese
decreto que incorpora entonces a estas
regiones el mundo entero Mira cómo
Ucrania continúa perdiendo territorio y
llueven críticas y sobre todo rechazos
sobre el kremlin siguen siendo también
un misterio las causas que llevaron a
esas fugas que se presentaron a lo largo
de la semana de las tuberías del
gasoducto del North Stream 1 y 2 y hay
algunos indicios de Sabotaje otros
señalan a Rusia pero
Moscú niega a ver participado incluso
calificaron este hecho como un acto
terrorista Mientras tanto también vemos
a miles de hombres rusos abandonando el
país todo esto para evitar ser
reclutados en el ejército para ser
enviados al frente de batalla en Ucrania
pues este es nuestro primer tema y
comienzo entonces con muni preguntándole
su perspectiva su opinión sobre lo que
deja esta semana en torno al conflicto
de Ucrania el mundo entero criticando a
Putin al presidente ruso pero poca
acción por parte de la comunidad
internacional y se van a anexar cuatro
regiones más
es impresionante porque lo que se está
viendo como una debilidad táctica de
Rusia se está convirtiendo en una
fortaleza política en una escalamiento
muy peligroso de este conflicto vamos
por parte por el lado de los referendos
o los referendos falsos que está
adelantando el presidente
Vladimir Putin lo que es esto es un
referendo a la población casi que con la
pistola en la 100 donde los resultados
que tienen más o menos un 99% de
aceptación por parte de la población Eso
quiere decir que hay un 100% de
seguridad de que el resultado está
amañado sin embargo esto como los medios
internacionales no son referendos para
que el público los crea sino para que el
mundo se sienta amenazado con respecto a
las fugas pues esto ha sido siempre el
northream siempre ha sido un punto
álgido en el conflicto entre Europa y
Rusia y Rusia Obviamente el cáncer Ruso
y ha tenido un poco más maniotados a
Europa sin duda otro tema en donde hay
muchas versiones de periodísticas muchas
versiones Según a quien le preguntan la
otan dice que esa voz Exacto terrorismo
etcétera etcétera vamos a consultarle
aquí en el estudio de France 24 a Carlos
y A Fátima que nos acompaña ya le doy la
palabra Alba Lucía No se preocupe Alba
Lucía ya va a estar con usted comienzo
Entonces por Fátima por las mujeres
opiniones sobre esto que estamos viendo
del mundo no hace nada para evitar esta
incorporación de esta región El caso es
que llevamos siete meses en guerra y que
la zona en frontera son las más
complicadas porque las zonas de fro
suelen ser donde más mezclada y de ambos
países no teniendo en cuenta que Rusia y
Ucrania tienen una mezcla cultural
brutal en yo creo que etapa Putin ha
dicho yo me voy alzar como vencedor Es
decir me voy alzar como vencedor frente
al mundo y ahora me anecciono esto y la
guerra merecida la pena cuando no se ha
hablado de todas estas muertes soldados
rusos que dicen en la otan que son
45.000 soldados rusos y en Estados
Unidos estaban diciendo en agosto que
son como 8 de 70.000 a 80.000 muertes no
entonces él se como que se proclamar a
vencedor y ahora la pelota de celenski
es no es que yo ahora quiero pertenecer
a la otan y ha vuelto a decir No no es
que ahora yo le voy a pasar a la otan y
a Estados Unidos la pelota la pelota
pasa entre Moscú kiev y ahora pasa a
Bruselas y Washington Carlos su opinión
sí Y ahí además un elemento que es Cómo
es la respuesta de la comunidad
internacional cuando vemos que en el
Consejo de Seguridad de la ONU pues
Rusia tiene el poder de Beto puede
llegar cualquier proyecto de resolución
puede llegar cualquier idea para tratar
de contener esto pero ahí no está el
escenario me quiero acoger a las
palabras de Ángela Merkel que era una
persona a la que Putin respetaba
muchísimo como canciller alemana que
decía hay que negociar con computer hay
que tratar de sentarlo a la mesa y hay
que tratar de hablar con él para que
esto no se nos vaya a salir de madre Y
de alguna manera esto tiene sentido y la
gran pregunta es cuál va a ser la opción
que va a optar la comunidad
internacional la militar con la otan
precisamente ya en la frontera rusa
entendiendo que Rusia se aneccionó esto
aunque aunque occidente no lo quiera
aceptar o va a ser la diplomática y
quienes van a estar en esa opción
diplomática la santa sede el bate Pues
el Papa Francisco que esta semana dijo
que había participado en la mediación
para la
y el intercambio de prisioneros quién va
a estar va a estar México alzó la mano
quién va a estar en esa mesa de
negociación quizás Aunque la Merkel no
lo sabemos el avión actor importante y
es Turquía que ha estado jugando en
ambas bandos y también un indicio sobre
eso que usted dice Carlos Ese llamado de
el gobierno de Estados Unidos a sus
ciudadanos abandonar el territorio ruso
lo más rápido posible eso puede dar un
indicio Hacia dónde se encarrila esta
situación para el cierre de este tema
Alba en la ciudad de Madrid Alba Lucía
adelante su opinión sus comentarios
Santiago pues ya me queda muy poco que
agregar después de mis compañeros Y como
decía Carlos pues ahora la pelota está
en que va a ser la comunidad
internacional que ya se ha dado cuenta
que con sanciones y con restricciones no
es como se quiere parar un poquito a
Vladimir Putin ahora lo que lo que lo
que interesa es saber cómo va a
reaccionar la otan en esa petición de
adhesión a la otan y me quedo con una
frase que dijo hace poco James que dice
es la escalada más seria en este momento
del conflicto con lo que hizo hoy
Vladimir desde gremlin muchos dicen que
estamos ante un punto de quiebre de este
conflicto del balucía continuó con usted
para preguntarle si usted desde su
análisis ha podido entender cuál es tal
vez ese nuevo orden mundial que está
intentando forzar y provocar el
presidente Putin que no es tan Claro
todavía entender que lo que quiere él y
como es ese orden mundial
Exactamente no es tan Claro porque
Aparentemente parece que en algunos
momentos está rendido pero no hay no hay
como un enemigo más débil al que temer
como él cuando se está como encarcelado
dentro de sus propios límites
194.000 rusos que ya están intentando
salir hoy otro ataque Entonces
definitivamente ese nuevo orden mundial
que quiere Vladimir Putin que para
muchos es una locura porque no se sabe
exactamente qué es lo que quiere y cómo
va a reaccionar a la comunidad
internacional Yo creo que tiene toda la
comunidad internacional como que si
usted se da cuenta ni Estados Unidos ni
la Unión Europea logran atinar con
ningún paso que dan porque Vladimir
Putin es totalmente impredecible con
cada paso que da bueno Carlos adelante
las claves para entenderlo están en el
discurso que pronunciaba este viernes en
el en la anexión en la firma de la
anexión hay una cantidad declaraciones
alrededor de su visión antioccidental
hablando de occidente nos ve como algo
que quiere colonizar como algo que
quiere esclavizar la pregunta también
podría uno hacérsela en sentido
contrario al Señor Putin quizás usted no
está haciendo lo mismo de modo que lo
que dice
nuestra compañera es de desde Madrid
llama mucho la atención Qué es lo que
está pensando este señor Sí además que
fue un discurso cargado de amenaza muy
sutil pero también un poco tendiendo la
mano a estar dispuesto a conversar y
analizar los temas Voy cerrando este
tema es el tema grueso de la semana
tiene muchísimas aristas pero también
hubo un tema muy importante en nuestra
región aquí en América Latina el mundo
también pudo ver con ojos con muchísima
expectativa como Colombia y Venezuela
dieron un paso adicional en esa
normalización de las relaciones
binacionales en un acto que fue bastante
informal lo podemos decir así y Con un
retraso por parte del presidente de
Colombia Gustavo Petro que llegó varios
minutos tarde a este encuentro y también
ante la ausencia del presidente o
representante del gobierno de Venezuela
Nicolás Maduro así estrecharon manos los
representantes de los dos gobiernos y
abrieron la frontera que permite
restablecer el intercambio comercial y
también esa vida transfronteriza que es
un punto muy importante para la vida
entre Colombia y Venezuela pero esta
abertura de la frontera o reapertura de
la frontera tiene mucho más allá veo A
Fátima por aquí alzando la mano para
comprar con este tema adelante estuve en
la frontera el fin de semana y yo estaba
varias veces en esa frontera entre
Colombia y Venezuela concretamente en
Villa del Rosario en el puente
internacional Simón Bolívar y bueno
llegó dos horas tarde Pedro
2 horas tarde es decir estaba programado
para las 9:30 y hubo un secretismo
también con los periodistas bastante
peculiar porque hasta el último minuto
no sabemos Quién viene maduro no viene y
yo creo que es por temas de seguridad
que eso no nos lo han dicho y solo Viene
un representante de Caracas que es un
ministro de industria y comercio que
verdaderamente Ninguno de los
periodistas colombianos conocíamos de
los que estábamos en la parte de
Colombia conocíamos y y también te digo
es muy compleja esta frontera se ha
abierto ojo con decir se abre la
frontera es decir sigue tal cual la
frontera en términos de movilidad humana
es decir siguen las mismas vallas siguen
pidiéndose la documentación a todos los
venezolanos que entran en Colombia y
colombianos porque es una zona de mucho
venezolano y colombiano que viven en
frontera
El llamamiento de la apertura de la
frontera supuso que de un día para otro
el día de la apertura de la frontera
pasaran 17.000 personas y al día
siguiente más de 20.000 esto hay que
decirlo del tránsito que va y viene para
que veamos la carga simbólica de este
puente en términos del país y te tengo
que ser honesta el día que anunciaron la
apertura yo creo que no hubo ningún paso
de tractomula ni de tracks es decir van
a han empezado ahora y se va a empezar
ahora a utilizar el tema del intercambio
de mercancía pero todavía quedan muchos
meses todavía por ver que se normalice
claro no esto reconstruir el comercio
binacional va a tomar meses Money su
perspectiva desde la ciudad de
Washington sobre este tema Bueno es una
una noticia muy importante yo soy
colombiana y sin duda la la he estado
siguiendo esto fueron siete años donde
estaba cerrado el tránsito y el comercio
la cerró acordémonos maduro
unilateralmente en el 2015 como una
especie de campaña contra el contrabando
en ese tiempo pues ha crecido y lo
sabemos todos las mafias el contrabando
exactamente y otros negocios ilegales
incluyendo en narcotráfico
recuerdo muy bien cuando trabajaba en en
comercio pues Venezuela siempre ha sido
siempre había sido el primer socio
comercial de Colombia y a pesar de las
diferencias políticas hay una gran
alineación entre los dos pueblos Hay un
problema y es que la frontera se puede
abrir pero los problemas de que hay en
la frontera y en los dos en los dos
lados no se están resolviendo Venezuela
sigue una democracia plena la ilegalidad
el narcotráfico el crimen organizado
sigue operando no está tan claro pues
que la la felicidad que hay entre los
entre la población y en el tema del
comercio se pueda convertir en una en
una mejoría de la parte de seguridad de
la parte de narcotráfico Y de todos los
males que que han acosado la frontera en
los últimos años
de la palabra Alba Lucía hay un punto
clave aquí y es porque Petro va solo a
la frontera y hay un dato que de pronto
nos lo puede ayudar a explicar Petro
obtuvo tan solo el 20.86% de los votos
en la segunda vuelta ganó allí Rodolfo
Hernández con el
77.84%. quiere decir que Gustavo Petro
está haciendo un movimiento hacia
ganarse la confianza el cariño Si se
quiere por lo menos tender la mano de
decir Estoy acá con los cucuteños con la
población de la frontera y aparecer como
la persona que está ayudando más
decididamente al restablecimiento de las
relaciones diplomáticas y por eso se ha
cuidado su cancillería de no tener la
foto todavía por ahora con Nicolás
Maduro esa foto esa foto podría haberle
traído muchos problemas al presidente
Petro comenzando su gobierno Alba Lucía
impresiones desde Madrid sobre este tema
Sí exactamente pues además de la
apertura comercial la de vuelos el freno
al Contrabando y y a las actividades
delictivas que se presentaban yo creo
que hay que darle mucho valor al mensaje
político que se dio con el con la
apertura de esa frontera y que Gustavo
Petro siempre pensó que había sido un
error esa ese cerco diplomático que
fomentó tanto el presidente Iván Duque y
que tampoco tuvo mucho éxito ni
repercusión internacional aquí creo que
también que la comunidad internacional
apoyado también un poco esa reapertura
el presidente específicamente Pedro
Sánchez de España cuando estuvo en
Bogotá sabemos que vio con muy buenos
ojos esa apertura diplomática con
Venezuela y que Gustavo Petro Pues no ha
actuado solo y que mensaje político de
restablecer esas relaciones políticas y
diplomáticas con con Venezuela es
también un mensaje hacia toda la región
un mensaje hasta todas la región Alba
Lucía Mónica Carlos y Fátima Quiero que
profundicemos en Precisamente en ese
mensaje que está mandando Colombia
porque Colombia fue el país que lideró
esta campaña internacional para tratar
de sacar a Nicolás maduro con el cerco
diplomático cuando llegó el presidente
Duque en su momento reconoció a Juan
guaidó como presidente de Venezuela y
ahora Colombia manda un mensaje
completamente distinto en cierta forma
desafiando también a Washington que su
gran Aliado en la región A qué está
jugando Colombia Qué tanto está
apostando Colombia con este mensaje y
apostándole el todo por el todo en sus
relaciones internacionales a traer a
Venezuela hacia el escenario
internacional veo que Alba Lucía está
con una opinión ahí por por soltarle
dejarla en la mesa adelante
Sí bueno yo yo básicamente creo que es
un poco los análisis que se han hecho y
es ese bloque regional que quiere
liderar Gustavo Petro con los gobiernos
de izquierda en la región y convertirse
en un bloque muy importante Ya no
solamente con Venezuela sino
posiblemente también con Brasil que
seguramente hablaremos más adelante
Entonces yo creo que el mensaje y la
digamos Yo creo que un poco el proyecto
que él tiene es un proyecto político de
izquierda a nivel regional para también
de dar un mensaje al mundo sobre sobre
esa nueva ese nuevo rumbo de la región
latinoamericana hacia la izquierda y ser
él el líder de esa izquierda cómo lo ve
muni
Yo creo que es una medida táctica no no
le veo tanto
planeaciones geopolítica
a la apertura de la frontera Yo creo que
es una medida táctica comercial política
sin duda Pero pero no necesariamente
parte de un gran plan en realidad no ha
delineado Petro un plan para la región
Estos son cosas que se que se asumen y
pienso que los conflictos que tiene
internamente lo están en este momento
consumiendo y que esta es parte de una
decisión de una promesa también de
campaña que tiene unas repercusiones
comerciales y políticas importantes la
verdad es que creo que el tema regional
es algo que se mira desde fuera con más
claridad desde dentro y aquí en el
estudio garantías para Colombia Fátima
Colombia está arriesgando mucho acá
Bueno yo creo que y así de acuerdo con
muni en cuanto a que yo no creo que haya
un gran plan yo lo que creo que está
pensando Petro en también la economía de
Cúcuta Cúcuta Era una ciudad que
dependía mucho de Venezuela
económicamente y Cúcuta está súper
empobrecida ha aumentado la criminalidad
una barbaridad Y aquí ha hecho un apunte
también Carlos que me ha encantado y es
cierto cuando hablas con los cucuteños
la gran mayoría de los cucuteños habían
votado por Rodolfo Entonces ahora que
viene yo creo que muchos deben de estar
agradecidos de que viniera Petro porque
la apertura comercial a que a la primera
que va a beneficiar y a los primeros que
me va a beneficiar son a esas ciudades
fronterizas Cúcuta en Colombia y San
Cristóbal y San Antonio de táchira en
Venezuela es decir hay unos movimientos
comerciales a todos los niveles de
mercancías que uno no se imagina de no
solo por Puente sino las trochas están
activas hay como decenas hay decenas de
trochas donde pasa mucha cantidad de
mercancías entonces lo que habría que
pensar es a nivel local regional pero en
pequeñito y luego ya a lograr Cómo puede
beneficiar ambos lados incluso ya
hablaban algunos empresarios en
Santander y norte de Santander es todo
el lado colombiano de utilizar puertos y
infraestructuras en el Golfo de
Maracaibo a través de la ciudad de
Maracaibo para sacar sus productos
porque les queda más cerca que llevarlos
hasta las costas colombianas o incluso
sacarlos por Buenaventura ya incluso
estaban hablando eso rápidamente Carlos
para el cierre de este tema algo para
decir una palabra clave en todo esto es
pragmatismo y aquí el presidente Gustavo
Petro la la vea la va aplicando el tema
de monómeros es clave monómeros es una
empresa de ambos países que hace un
tiempo la obtuvo en su poder
el gobierno de Hugo Chávez que produce
fertilizantes y en este momento del
contexto global cierto donde los grandes
productores de fertilizantes están en
una situación de conflicto bélico pues
hace mucho sentido que dentro de
Colombia haya un productor de
fertilizantes pero resulta que con el
reconocimiento del presidente Iván Duque
a Juan guaidó Para pasarle monómeros
para que monómeros pudiera funcionar
necesita una certificación de los
Estados Unidos dado que el estado
venezolano casi en su conjunto está
sancionado por los Estados Unidos de
modo que aquí también va a entrar a
jugar qué va a pasar con Estados Unidos
como el presidente Petro va a ser de
alguna manera mediador entre Estados
Unidos y Venezuela en el pragmatismo que
incluso Washington ha mostrado para
poder que monómeros funcione y que no
tenga los problemas que tienen el resto
del Estado venezolano Ahí va a haber en
los próximos meses algo bien interesante
que vamos a ver cómo Petro se va a
mostrar como esa ficha que va a tratar
de unir esas dos partes volvemos a ese
punto de Liderazgo liderazgo regional
liderazgo en ese acercamiento Washington
porque lo necesita uno de los mensajes
de Petro ha sido Quiero llevar
producción agrícola industrializar el
campo y necesita fertilizante claro y
necesita fertilizantes baratos pasemos a
otro tema destacado de la semana porque
también muchísima expectativa sobre lo
que pueda acontecer en Brasil este país
se prepara para las que pueden llegar a
ser las elecciones más representativas
de la historia reciente del gigante
suramericano
156 millones de ciudadanos van a elegir
al nuevo presidente es el padrón
electoral más grande de la historia de
Brasil recordemos Pues que Brasil es el
motor económico de nuestra región unas
elecciones que han estado marcadas por
la polarización la falta de propuestas
por parte de los candidatos también las
los constantes ataques verbales entre
los candidatos sobre todo entre
bolsonaro y Lula Entonces cuál es el
panorama el actual presidente Yair
bolsonaro aspira la reelección Mientras
que el expresidente Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva aspira a un tercer mandato
comienzo preguntándole Alba Lucía en la
ciudad de Madrid qué piensa usted va a
haber segunda vuelta allí en Brasil y
como ve ustedes escenario que ha
planteado bolsonaro de no reconocer unos
resultados si él no es el presidente
según los últimos sondeos yo sí creo que
va a ser Inevitable que haya una segunda
vuelta No creo que en la primera vuelta
se decida nada y creo que van a jugar
muchos muchos actores aquí una un papel
muy importante por un lado Pues están
las redes sociales los medios de
comunicación que como vimos Hace cuatro
años fueron el arma fundamental de
bolsonaro también las iglesias
evangélicas que también ayudaron mucho a
bolsonaro en esta en esa contienda
electoral pero yo creo que también todo
lo que está pasando Brasil la tragedia
social la tragedia económica todos los
los muertos asesinatos que hubo que
nunca se lograron aclarar Pues yo creo
que van a darle si todo parece indicar
la victoria a anulada Silva que aunque
bolsonaro lo ha intentado insultar como
lo vimos en el último debate yo creo que
que los brasileños van a dar un cambio
otra vez y van a volver a Lula yo les
pregunto a los cuatro si ustedes
pudieron ver el debate presidencial el
último debate presidencial que fue
realizado por la cadena globo hubo
muchísimas críticas interna por la
pobreza política del debate la falta de
nivel por parte de los candidatos que
piensan por este lado y empecé a verlo
se cortó la conexión con globo para los
que estábamos no teníamos la conexión
directa con la televisión brasileña y
bueno lo que me extrañó mucho él había
pues no me llamó mucho la atención
porque me pareció disperso y había un
cura ortodoxo que era el que le
preguntaba a bolsonaro unas preguntas
que eran como muy suaves y no terminaba
de entender que fueron debate
presidenciales tengo que ser honesta
luego se corta la conexión y ya no pude
ver más y luego he visto todos los que
son los resultados que han dicho los
medios y periodistas pero me ha parecido
un poco surrealista y tengo que decirlo
porque que haya un cura ortodoxo que es
falso y que hace preguntas a bolsonaro
termina insultando a Lula me parecía un
poco extraño la verdad y es algo que
hemos visto a lo largo de las últimas
campañas presidenciales en América
Latina Múnich es un Común denominador
pocas propuestas muchos ataques pobreza
de debate y los ciudadanos en
incertidumbre
estaba pensando justamente eso Santiago
Brasil es una especie de de espejo de lo
que han sido las las elecciones
recientemente miremos pues evidentemente
la de Colombia tiene muchísimas
parecidos en términos de los extremos
que representaron la voluntad Popular en
esta que es la una de las democracias
más grandes del mundo esto es el el
registro también casi con resultado al
revés de las de las elecciones de Italia
la semana pasada donde estaban también
enfrentados los extremos tenemos a Lula
un icono de la izquierda en
latinoamericana ese sí lleno de
escándalos de corrupción que lo han
digamos lo han sacado de la de la de la
vida pública durante varios años este
regreso sería pues épico para Brasil los
problemas a resolver son los mismos en
el mundo entero es la eso igual la
pobreza de debate la recuperación
económica aquí uno puede enfrentar la
inflación la corrupción son problemas
horizontales y esta polarización
política es el resultado de cómo los
políticos de los dos lados rompieron la
la el vínculo de confianza con los
votantes aquí están en juego cosas
grandísimas el Amazonas en la
deforestación y y estar en la misma
democracia cuando un candidato y eso no
es solamente en Brasil que se ha dicho
que se va a aferrar al poder porque las
las las elecciones no son transparentes
pero hemos visto hasta aquí en
Washington Y eso realmente es una
preocupación Grande del estado de la
Democracia Este es un programa de
periodistas y creo que es una reflexión
muy grande que tenemos que hacer desde
los medios Es que es que dice mucho
cuando el mismo presidente
habla mal del sistema democrático del
sistema electoral que lo ha elegido tres
años atrás eso dice mucho del estado en
el que se encuentra la democracia
latinoamericana para el cierre de este
tema Carlos
la elección en Brasil es clave para el
medio ambiente solo hay coincidido
muchas voces alrededor de esto por qué
Porque evolucionar ha sido un hombre que
durante su gobierno ha desconocido la
situación de deforestación de la selva
amazónica Y esperan que sea el gobierno
del partido de los trabajadores el
gobierno de la izquierda el que le
devuelva de alguna manera la Esperanza a
esos sectores ambientalistas y dicen que
de alguna manera si continúa la la
deforestación hasta de un 25% de la capa
vegetal de la amazonía pues puede haber
un punto de inflexión muy complejo no
solamente para Sudamérica sino para el
planeta entero de modo que es una
lección que más allá de los ataques Más
allá de las ofensas que fueron en el
debate muchísimas con momentos muy
complejos ahí hay una situación por la
cual yo creo que todos debemos estar muy
atentos el domingo que es lo que va a
pasar en Brasil Claro que sí para el
cierre este tema pregunta para los
cuatro segunda vuelta sí o no y algún
ganador comienzo con Fátima va a haber
segunda vuelta en la primera vuelta
incluso puede que sea hasta bueno que
haya segunda vuelta y va a ganar Lula
Lula por este lado Carlos va a haber
segunda vuelta es lo que me dicen
colegas en Brasil va a haber segunda
vuelta algún ganador Lula Lula celular
segunda vuelta ya nos decía que sí pero
algún ganador sí
Hay una posibilidad de que Lula gane en
primera vuelta Bueno una opinión Ahí
vamos a verlo vamos a confirmar el
domingo en las elecciones
en Brasil elecciones que tienen en vilo
a la región entera vamos llegando ya el
bloque final del programa justamente
esta semana esta casa Franz 24 estuvo de
cumpleaños cinco años de transmisión
ininterrumpida para toda América Latina
desde nuestra redacción en la ciudad de
Bogotá de nuestra redacción hermana en
la ciudad de París para conmemorar Este
quinto aniversario presentamos tres
nuevos programas justamente uno de esos
nuevos programas es una semana en el
mundo y en el marco de esta celebración
podemos conversar entonces sobre el
futuro de la televisión como medio
informativo Y esa disputa que está
teniendo con los medios digitales y
también quiero poner sobre la mesa el
cubrimiento de los temas internacionales
que es lo que estamos debatiendo acá de
los diferentes hechos destacados de la
semana qué opiniones tienen ustedes de
el cubrimiento de las noticias
internacionales ha sido un año muy
difícil para los periodistas pandemia
guerras elecciones controversias
medioambientales políticas comenzó por
Munich en la ciudad de Washington ha
sido un año muy difícil es un espejo el
periodismo de la sociedad el descontento
de la gente con el periodismo va
creciendo como lo va creciendo con todas
las instituciones es el momento más
importante para proteger la libertad de
prensa de todos los flancos por parte de
la violencia de los mismos gobiernos de
las de las grandes corporaciones porque
la el periodismo en este momento es uno
de los bastiones de democracia que
quedan y hay que preservarlos como sea y
termino diciendo que la tecnología como
una herramienta puede ser un excelente
apoyo para el periodismo no para el
Facebook y para los ciberataques que es
para lo que más se ha conocido la
tecnología en este momento es una
instrumento de verdad y termino diciendo
que Feliz cumpleaños atrás 24 Gracias
Mori en Madrid Alba Lucía usted viene de
la radio pero Le repito la pregunta que
estás Yo haciendo al principio sobre
esta competencia que estamos teniendo
con los medios digitales si Estamos
perdiendo terrenos los de la televisión
usted que está en radio que es un medio
que también pensaron que iba a
desaparecer y la radio se mantiene
fuerte
la radio se mantiene yo también estuve
en televisión
el periodismo pero debido a los últimos
acontecimientos como sabían dice así un
año muy difícil he visto otra vez
grandes reportajes grandes periodistas
grandes descubrimientos utilizando todo
tipo de herramientas tecnológicas y la
verdad es que creo que el lo mismo como
tal de los que son Realmente periodistas
no los que están en redes sociales y que
son blogueros O youtubers sino los
periodistas De verdad están haciendo un
gran trabajo y creo que todas estos
retos y estos desafíos que nos ha
impuesto el orden mundial en que vivimos
ha hecho que se vuelvan a ser muy buenos
trabajos en tanto en radio en televisión
y en prensa y creo que el periodismo
excelente que se han hecho en en Las
Guerras en la pandemia pues o sea nos ha
dado muy buena información pues hemos
visto por ejemplo las manifestaciones en
Irán que entrar a Irán a hacer
cubrimiento Será muy complicado Carlos
Pues pienso que hacer periodismo es caro
en tiempo y en dinero y que haya una
casa como Franz 24 apostando
precisamente al equilibrio a escuchar
todas las voces a hacer nuevos programas
pues habla muy bien del trabajo y de la
confianza que tiene la audiencia en
Francia 24 que creo que es el verdadero
motivo de celebración pienso que hay una
necesidad también de conectar audiencias
pienso jóvenes entre 18 o 25 años que
hoy están viendo más tiktok más
Instagram y ellos también van a crecer
como nosotros cierto va a llegar a una
edad en la que les va a interesar la
información les va a interesar las
noticias creo que ahí está el El Gran
desafío como conectamos con periodismo
con información seria investigada y
confrontada con datos verificados pero
llevando a nuevas narrativas Fátima
Bueno yo pienso que el periodismo está
más vivo que nunca y el periodismo
Internacional de france24 lo aplaudo y
quiero daros la Enhorabuena por haber
creado esto también en Colombia en un
país donde hay una alta tensión
permanente política social y a todos los
niveles entonces Os doy la Enhorabuena
por estos cinco años verdaderamente con
poder contratar a jóvenes periodistas
para que hagan periodismo internacional
a día de hoy me parece un privilegio y
que desde aquí lo estáis haciendo Chapó
y es lamentable bueno esto Esto es muy
destacado también pero vemos noticias
que de pronto nos bajan un poco el ánimo
y son esos 380 periodistas de la
redacción Internacional de la bbc que
van a dejar sus trabajos precisamente
porque la la bbc va a hacer recortes
considerables en su presupuesto y le va
a apostar a los temas digitales
y va a sacar presupuesto de los
descubrimientos internacionales para
pasarlos a la redacción digital ahí
vemos un poco las prioridades de muchas
de las cadenas finalmente esto también
es un negocio en cierta forma y hay que
producir ganancias para poder sostener
todo esto que está aquí en términos de
infraestructura me queda un minutico
rápido quiero preguntarles y que sean
muy puntuales por favor en sus
respuestas los temas que tienen en la
lupa para la próxima semana ustedes en
su redacciones en sus artículos en los
temas que ustedes estén trabajando Alba
Lucía en Madrid
pues el lunes los premios Nobel estamos
pendientes de de esa lista que siempre
todos los años nos emociona y que
tenemos que buscar a los personajes Así
que el lunes empezamos a trabajar con
todos los premios Nobel que se
anunciaron primer tema
la geopolítica del mundial de fútbol
este esperado partido entre Irán y
Estados Unidos y tantas otras historias
políticas que hay detrás del mundial
Claro que sí por este lado Fátima bueno
Yo sigo con la frontera Colombia
Venezuela y voy a estar pendiente de lo
que pase en las próximas semanas porque
yo creo que la reapertura va a ser lenta
y luego quería hacer un anuncio de los
premios Gabo que ya se han anunciado
esta mañana y que va a ser en los
premios de grado por primera vez en
Bogotá entonces que bienvenidos todos
los periodistas que vengan para acá y
Bueno pues que va a ser muy bonito que
se haga en Bogotá la invitación para
todos los colegas periodistas Carlos en
la redacción Internacional de la Radio
Nacional de Colombia estamos analizando
a profundidad los efectos de la
militarización en México que está
también teniendo unos efectos en materia
política para el gobierno de López
Obrador y en materia derechos humanos
para los ciudadanos en general allí en
México Bueno le dejo ahí añadidura en el
tema de México esas filtraciones que
hubo al presidente mexicano no está bien
de salud y hay muchos problemas con los
temas militares allí en México
seguramente va a estar sobre la mesa de
las redacciones el tema de México y del
presidente López Obrador en los próximos
días Pues les Quiero agradecer a los
cuatro por habernos acompañado en esta
conversación rápida pero divertida y
sencilla fue muy interesante conocer sus
puntos de vista les agradezco haber
estado con nosotros en el programa en
este Debut y ustedes por supuesto Pueden
seguir dejando todos sus comentarios a
través de las redes sociales y Pueden
seguir en sintonía de France 24
[Música]